hungry
let's crush it why are we about to eat
it hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and since you guys loved my
previous turning your trigger foods into
hunger crushing combos video i thought
we're gonna make this a regular series
oh yeah folks i'm i'm more excited about
this than you guys probably are because
it means i get to eat so many fun foods
that you know maybe i haven't really
thought of it before so this week we're
going to be doing candy we've got some
ramen pizza fried chicken
chips
oh
it's gonna be a good week now before we
even get into it hit me up in the
comments below if you want me to turn
your classic trigger food or fear food
into a hunger crushing combo okay but
let me just like hop in here for a
second to talk about my sponsor
squarespace now if you're not familiar
with squarespace it's an all-in-one
platform to run your business whether
you're looking to build a website blog
online store or use their marketing
tools and analytics i am admittedly not
very tech savvy even though my whole job
kind of involves online tech so
squarespace is great for folks like me
who really can't be bothered tinkering
with the back end and like coding and
all that complicated stuff
we just want things to work
so they have some awesome features that
allow you to connect your social media
accounts collect donations blog comment
and gather analytics literally it's the
one stop shop of websites so you can
check out squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com
abbey sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain also
don't forget to check out my general
disclaimer on screen here and in the
description below including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always you can feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are new here
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a video and also
follow me at abby's kitchen over on
instagram and on tick tock all right
let's make some food now i want to make
it very clear that there's nothing wrong
there's no shame with enjoying these
trigger foods or fear foods on the
regular all by themselves without any
hunger crushing compounds going on but i
wanted to show you how you can
incorporate them into everyday meals and
snacks in a way that make you feel your
best so that you can enjoy them more
regularly and we can strip them of their
fear food or kind of trigger food status
so on that note let's do it all right
folks another day another hunger
crushing combo and this is one that was
highly requested
candy
to the candy shop
so i mean there's so many ways you could
go about this but i feel like my hunger
crushing combo idea will really apply
anything and it's when i'm filming this
right now it's almost halloween so we're
gonna get a lot of candy in this house
and i always buy the good stuff that i
actually want to eat because like
sometimes i just want like a little
little something something and it's you
know it always just hits hits the spot
so licorice came up a lot
on my youtube channel request i guess a
lot of you guys like licorice i also
like licorice except for not black
licorice because that is nasty um but i
guess red licorice is not real licorice
but it's delicious so i thought that
these would be fun to make a little
hunger crushing combo with so let's do
it mmm they're so good okay very serious
question were you team twizzlers or red
vines we didn't have red vines growing
up a google search tells me that this is
a heated debate so obviously i was team
twizzlers and i prefer a twizzler to a
nip but i felt like the nib just lended
themselves better to a hunger crushing
combo so we're going with it and we're
taking that
oh no
we're taking these bad boys
to this
so as you can see what we got going on
here we got some nibs on top for the fun
uh we've got some walnuts here some
healthy fats and protein and fiber it is
a hunger crushing combo all on its own
of course and then some popcorn also for
some fiber and this is going to make an
amazing snack mix so let's put her
together
[Music]
sweet salty crunchy chewy come on what
more could you want
all right folks
let's do it again today we are going to
do one of my personal favorites
potato chips oh you like potato chips
because if you do you out of luck cause
i'm not sharing mine these are
and i'm partial to the ruffle clearly
because i bought this bag specifically
for this video and
she didn't make it
but there's still time of course to make
this into a more satiating balance snack
so that's we're going to do today we're
going to pair this with a homemade greek
yogurt french onion dip and she's going
to be good so
let's do it so first thing we're going
to do is finely chop one onion
saute that in a little bit of olive oil
with a little bit of garlic as well
all right now she's looking caramelizy
a little bit of worcestershire sauce
all right then we got some plain full
fat greek yogurt here and we're just
going to add our onions
[Music]
smells so good
now we dip
guys how excited are you about this epic
snack plate i am
so excited anything to do with ruffles
chips um plain ruffles
beat out plain ladies
any effing day of the week am i right
lips fighting words
tell me i'm right in the comments below
this smells so good
all right we got our salty delicious
chippy chips we've got some veggie
action so we've hitting it with the
fiber here we've got fiber protein and
healthy fats and the greek yogurt
concoction
i'm excited to dig in and this is going
to be so satisfying
checking all the boxes when i dip you
dip we dip
cheers
[Music]
[Music]
happy friday [ __ ]
yes i just watched mean girls last night
so i'm feeling a little extra sassy but
it's friday and on fridays
we order pizza
pizza time
cue the angels singing cue the birds
singing everyone sing singing because
it's a pizza day ah pizza hut uh pizza
hut remember guys do you guys remember
that song my 90s friends my 90s kids
will hello hugs it's straight phone the
electronic game with the talking phone
um so we're gonna have a little pizza
party here and we're gonna turn it into
a hunger crushing combo which
in my books is not that hard to do like
we do not need to be worried and fearing
pizza because pizza in my books
can be a built-in hunger crushing combo
and we're gonna add in a little extra
nutrition just for good measure so let
me show you how i do it first of all
having this pizza next to my face is a
bit of an occupational hazard because i
am not going to get to the end of my
sentence to explain to you how to make
pizza on your crushing combo before i
just shove this in my face but anyways
it is it smells divine so what i did
here oh my gosh it smells so good what
did you put in this
so we've got some protein in the chicken
and of course you know if you're making
your own pizza you can also just throw
on any leftover protein that you have in
the house could also be tofu for my
vegan friends we got some pesto for some
healthy fats um we got cheese for fat
we've got the crust i chose a whole
wheat option but honestly anything will
do because we've also got veggies in
here and the kicker is how we're gonna
serve this up to make it a really good
satisfying balanced meal so take a look
at my plate
[Music]
okay so the pizza place that i ordered
from also did like diy salads which i
love because you can customize them to
add in lots of nutritious little num
noms so in my salad right here i've got
lots of veggies i think there's tomatoes
carrots mushrooms um i've also got
edamame for some extra protein and a
variety of seeds and nuts in there for
some healthy fats plus of course an
apple cider vinaigrette oh i also put
goat's cheese in here which i absolutely
love i don't want to sell without cheese
that's just me and then of course we got
our pizza so look at this gorgeous
colorful plate
yes that my friends is a meal and so we
can just like split this i'm gonna split
this with my hubs half a salad half a
pizza and i'm gonna feel amazingly
satisfied oh i'm so excited to dig in
this is torture just to have to talk
while
holding this plate of deliciousness
let's get in here
[Music]
the pesto on there
killer i'm not ever having pizza without
pesto from now on
uh but i gotta say i just have to tell
everyone right now that it is also okay
to have pizza with no salad on the side
that's not what this is about and it's
also totally okay to have the whole
pizza yourself and not share it i do
that too but the point of this is to
learn how to build out meals that feel
good emotionally that are emotionally
satisfying but also really physically
saturating as well and i mean you can
see i didn't even finish that whole
plate because i just feel good right now
but the bottom line is is that i built a
meal that was so packed with delicious
things and really kind of satisfying
filling foods as well that i just don't
feel the need to overeat all right it is
lunch time and i am hungry so i ordered
one of a lot of your kind of trigger
foods fried chicken it's chicken it's
fried chips fried chicken i like fried
chicken
oh my goodness who am i
she's a crispy how are we going to make
this into a hunger crushing combo well i
thought we would build this into like an
actual
more handheld meal and that means
getting a little veg in there and also
kind of like a whole grain bun so let's
do it all right so i've got a nice whole
grain bun here we've got some avocado
she's a beaut okay that's a little
that's a big one
i've got some greens
some tomat
big
crunchy good one get down there
then actually though we can't forget
about
the pickle you forgot the pickles
just gonna sneak that in there get
together then i ordered this also from
the fried chicken place it's like a
cabbage kale slaw so i thought that was
really beautiful and looks delish
love me a good slaw
oh look at that monster
that
is a meal
hello
it's so good
it's a little spicy oh i lost avocado
damn
get in there
just shove it in
oh no
i need a bib
i need a bib for this one oh my god
delicious seasoned skin got of course
our protein in the chicken we've got our
healthy fats in that avocado we've got
lots of fiber in the whole bun and all
those vegetables we added on the
sandwich and in the kale slaw what's not
to love
[Music]
all right lovelies next one
ramen noodles
mystery noodles specifically these bring
back so many memories okay raise your
hand and i think only the elder
millennials are gonna get this but raise
your hand if you used to
get one of these in your lunchbox for
school and like crush it into small
little pieces and then we will put the
seasoning pack inside the plastic bag
and just eat it
dry this like super salty kind of like
chicken soup flavored just like tingle
on the tongue crunchiness it was the
best snack and a lot of you guys told me
that ramen noodles like this were one of
your fear foods and i have to say like i
order ramen from ramen restaurants all
the time and i actually think it's an
inherently quite balanced meal right you
got your carbs in there with the noodles
most of them come with some kind of
protein top there um there's like an egg
in there there's some kind of meat
there's vegetables usually tofu
lots of great options um but i thought
we would switch things up and i would
turn
this little
little darling into a really naturally
nourishing hunger crushing combo of a
meal and i'm actually really looking
forward to eating this for dinner so
let's do it okay so first of all worth
noting that i'm not actually following a
strict recipe we're going to make a
green curry shrimp and lots of veggies
because i had tons of vegetables left
over in the fridge and i want to use
them up before the weekend so yeah
follow along let's see how it goes
got some onion
minced up ginger and garlic
a little salt
a little peps
got some green
curry paste
no clue how much we're gonna need but
we're bringing it
got some butternut squash
got a can of diced tomatoes
lots of cauliflower not sure i'm gonna
use all of it
but we shall see
that's how we roll
i think we're gonna need
more tomatoes
let's see what we can find okay
found some tomato sauce throwing that in
and i'm gonna put our shrimpies on the
top and then season everything and then
we'll just let it cook and see what
happens
throw a little hot water in there
aloe dorm room days
there we go
i'm gonna add in some snap peas
and i've got some water chestnuts which
i'm obsessed with
and then i've got some leftover coconut
milk just to balance everything out
check that out
all right so what do we got well we've
got our protein in the shrimp we've got
some healthy fats i added some cashews
in there tons of fiber rich vegetables
um i was tasting as i went because i
wasn't following a recipe and i added
just a little bit of maple syrup and
some fresh lime juice just to balance
out those flavors
check it out
the kids are gonna like this
everyone's gonna like this
also just an fyi if you did want to have
a packet of these just on their own
cooked or raw as we used to do in grade
school
just as an fyi one package has 10 grams
of protein so not all is lost here folks
you've you've got some protein built
right in
to these and i mean they taste
really good so i would say for one of
those meals where you just like need to
learn quick fast cheap and cheerful
it's not
a terrible option
just saying
but this
this is a meal
[Music]
well folks that is all that i have for
you guys today if you love this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up thank you
again to squarespace for sponsoring and
leave me a comment below on your trigger
food or your fear food that you want to
see me incorporate into a hunger
crushing combo um also don't forget to
subscribe to this channel follow me on
social media at abby's kitchen if you're
not already and i think we're gonna do a
holiday one for next month so if you any
holiday sugar foods or fear foods let me
know i'm very excited to get into the
holiday spirit so i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]